is a new brand on the scene called alif
they make hundred percent halal raw cat
food there are countless health benefits
to this new raw diet check them out on
instagram at alif dot uk they do monthly
subscription boxes and you can get 10
discount on their two week trial box
with my code ali10 check them out now
and let your cat enjoy some nice food
assalamu alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends i
hope you guys are well before i start i
want to swap them i want to praise allah
subhanahu talah the most merciful the
most trust of praise his glory and
gratitude belong to him that's why this
video at one moment when i saw this
sister
walking on her own
and a pile of pigs and dirtbags these
filthy dogs
all together maybe there's about 100 of
them
hurling abuse shouting i don't know what
they're shouting they sound like animals
creatures cows they sound like cows like
donkeys screaming
at one moment i felt sorry for the
sister
and i was like i wish me and some
brothers were there i just wish like
just me and some brothers
were just there
but then again i
looked and watched that video again and
there's another one where which you're
going to see yourself
when she comes there with a motorbike
watch this because while like she was
like a gangster
when i looked i was above forget the
brothers
this sister dealt with them on her own
oh my gosh
let's watch that video and let's come
back
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
now guys you saw that with your own eyes
i beg any of you guys to come and tell
me
that sister was not gangsta and when i
mean gans don't get twisted i'm not
talking about ganga i'm just trying to
say like that sister owned the place
she came there with a motorbike put a
motorbike down yeah
looked like a jeep well that was she was
walking she was walking like i got shook
i was like yo like something man is
about to happen
she walks and she doesn't even ignore
them but she turns at them like little
dogs you know when dogs are barking
right right around they're barking like
dogs shut up dog you said shut up dog
shut up yeah you say
he says if she went and she screamed
i don't know what she said but while i
it must be the best thing ever she said
i don't know what she said i don't even
understand it but it's so amazing
i'm here to salute this sister i'm not
here to do a video of feeling sorry for
her exception
that sister was a g
my gosh she went there gave them a piece
of their piece of her mind slap slap
slap and walked off turn their back like
dogs
when dogs come what did they do like
dogs they followed her and she just went
about her business and went straight to
where she needed to go wallahi i have
not seen anyone
lack a g
like mashallah wow in that abaya with
that you know nikhil cover in her face
whatever it may be she came there like a
g
slapped them up silly and walked off
like a jeep may allah bless you my
sister what a courageous woman
what a courageous woman that she
will stand
and defend her right to wear her hijab
yes for the sake of allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
while it's such a thing and subhanallah
look at the climate she's living in yeah
there's probably a genocide on the verge
and they are sticking firm may allah
grant you the highest ranks of german
sister while i'm in dua for you your
family sisters like you we salute you
while adam you guys are the backbone of
this ummah they will not leave us to be
yourself they will not
so
salute to my dear sister and for filthy
scums yeah islamophobes like rotten wood
apus and the rest who play a role in the
hate increasing in india and around the
world we salute her may allah bless her
what a warrior share this video far and
wide
far and wide
till next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh